et bah cohade le patron de lehman
qianmen atlantic qui est responsable la
tragédie de lac-mégantic compte sur ces
assurances pour répondre à la mise en
demeure de la ville après être resté
plutôt discret depuis la catastrophe du
6 juillet dernier il a répondu aux
questions un peu plus tôt de mon
collègue denis martin chabot je paye nos
avocats ont été en contact avec les
avocats de la ville alors je pense que
la ville de comprendre pourquoi nous
avons des problèmes à payer ses factures
cela a à voir avec notre couverture
d'assurance et la réticence des
assurances a commencé honnêtement
comment expliquer cela vous avez des
assurances qui peuvent payer mais ce
sont eux qui ont des problèmes pour
payer vous vous paierez si vous vous le
pouviez vous le pouvez vous payeriez
immédiatement ci comprend bien les zac
nous payerions nous nous nous assurons
des problèmes légaux que je ne suis pas
en position de décrire à savoir quand
ils vont commencer à effectuer des
témoins et quelles formes prendront ces
paiements ma prochaine question je pense
que vous avez aussi entendu corner du
fait que le berghof québec a émis une
ordonnance pour forcer votre compagne et
deux sur company of the west wing
pétrolier de payer et de mettre sur pied
un plan pour nettoyer le désastre dans
la rivière est ce que vous savez comment
vous allez y répondre ben nous avons
reçu
cette ordonnance est essentiellement
c'est une ordonnance qui nous demande de
faire exactement ce que nous faisons
depuis que cette tragédie est arrivé là
alors nous continuons à gérer les
contracteurs puis nous faisons tout ce
que nous pouvons pour mettre en oeuvre
exactement ce que leur dôme ans
l'ordonance contient je comprends que
ceci va coûter beaucoup d'argent votre
compagnie peut-elle payer pour cela si
jamais les assureurs eux ne paient pas
un bain je pense que demain de manière
ultime se laisse assurances ont payé
avec la fin des assurances manifestement
nous pouvons continuer cet effort
pendant assez longtemps
et quel avenir voyez-vous pour aimer
mode
après tout ce qui s'est passé abbas est
une question difficile à laquelle répond
nous étudions tout cela et nous
considérons les options qui s'offrent à
nous actuellement seul à voir avec les
discussions en cours avec les assureurs
les compagnies d'assurances devrais-je
dire d'accord direz-vous qu'à un certain
moment la faillite pourrait être dans
les étoiles surtout si vous ne pouvez
plus faire passer des trains à travers
lac-mégantic ou autour et ben lui ni
nous allons
pensez mais passons continuer nos
opérations à échelle réduite dirais-je
indépendamment du fait que les iliad et
d'autres facteurs qui implique aussi la
compagnie maintenant est ce que la
compagnie recherche fait à se mettre
sous la protection de la faillite dans
une telle situation c'est quelque chose
à considérer mais n'avons pas pris des
dissidences et des faits tu as fait
c'est tout pour moi monsieur bakhyt y
aurait-il quelque chose que vous
voudriez shooté à ce moment ci eh ben je
voudrais continuer à exprimer le fait
que je suis dévastée par ce qui s'est
passé là-bas nous parlons d'argent et
sein de rachète pas les pertes de vies
humaines ce site un désastre qui je
pense sera avec nous pendant v long
moment avec moi personnellement avec
notre personnel et aussi les résidents
les citoyens de lac mégantic
mais je regrette extrêmement quelque
chose comme cela se soit passé
j'espère que nous pourrons aider à
alléger le problème actuel et faire tout
ce que nous pouvons pour mitiger les
dommages qui ont été créés